[Applause]
hey everyone welcome back to behind the
screens I've got my guest this week Dave
two small chin I've got it the small
change a small chin pronouncing it right
we have a lot to talk about I haven't
seen you in a while I want to call out
your shirt because you explained it to
me and I love it
thank you yes my wife Evelyn Lee makes
custom shirts for me sometimes just a
special presence and after I worked with
Mark Hamill on Supergirl
Mark Hamill the Luke Skywalker Joker
slash every other amazing iconic thing
he's done but this is a design that she
came up with it made it's it's Luke
going through the glass at Cloud City
and as soon as she handed it to me I was
just like I have my own shows right yeah
yes oh yeah yeah yeah in fact I knew
that when I first met Eve we were in New
York and I was working on a short film
and she is a favor to someone the
director she was shooting some pictures
behind the scenes because my wife
doesn't she's not kind of in this side
in this business at all she's a painter
but um so we started dating and the
first time that I got to you know hang
out at her place to play Scrabble or
whatever you do at someone's place she
had the dark night and she had paint
girl stuff around and I was like oh man
this woman is my soul mate did she
already know who you were when you met
her no she she eaves loves films but she
doesn't really connect actors with
characters which is a really cool thing
she has this masterful kind of sense of
suspension of disbelief so not that I
was somebody to be recognized but when
we first met she was just like oh this
is some guy on this weird I was doing
this awesome or short film for these
these friends of mine who were had
written and directed it and it was took
place during Fashion Week and we were
shooting a scene at a salon in DUMBO in
Brooklyn and Eve was taking pictures
behind the scenes and shooting some
interviews for them as a favor and and I
saw this woman from across the salon and
she
such a cool my wife looks like the one
who should be in Hollywood like she
looks like she looks like she is
confirmed and she could be like an
assassin in Kill Bill she could be you
know I mean she's kind of a badass hmm
and I walked it up to her I was like who
are you she was like oh I have to
interview you come on let's talk and we
just talked all day and anyway then
being that she is a huge fan of the Dark
Knight and she was a huge fan of stuff I
didn't want to say like oh I realize
you're a fan of all the stuff and by the
way I I was in the dark because if I
would have she would have been like so
or or she would have been like who but
no she when when she did put two and two
together it was cool how it happened and
she was like oh your crazy mother flower
that crazy guy I was like catch oh yeah
yeah he was the crazy guy in the dark
night and a bunch of other things that
you've done the crazy guy yeah for all
the crazy guys that you've played I mean
ant-man the flash Gotham did a movie
with Mark Hamill oh yeah you've got
Blade Runner coming out this weekend
that you did with Harrison Ford and Ryan
Gosling I mean oh yeah loving this stuff
absolutely and then you've been a part
of everything you love
I keep pinching myself and and and and
if it's a dream I don't want to wake up
you know I grew up living in my
imagination as we all did you know a ton
and it's just the most unreal thing that
I get to suit up and go to work and and
beyond the you know the sets of these of
these projects where they're bringing
all this stuff to actual like life you
know and with heroes of mine mark my
gosh getting to know mark and and and
and getting to work you know in any
capacity with him or sitting last night
last night we had the the the premiere
for Blade Runner 20 49 and I'm sitting
you know and down away from Harrison m-f
and for like yeah come on man are you
joking I wanted to
like crap my wife's like don't don't
ugly cry right now you have to look
cooler at the Dolby theater there's a
lot of people here you got to keep it
together
[Music]
yeah and you've worked with so many of
these legends I mean like Michael
Douglas in ant-man
Mark Hamill Harrison Ford is it I mean
how do you go up to these people and
talk to them initially because it for me
it's like well I don't want to interview
certain people because I'm afraid to
meet my heroes sure yeah yeah no I stand
I still get nervous and that's a good
thing I think it probably would would
make me sad the day that I show up to
work with with with a Michael Douglas or
with organ you know the chance to be in
a scene with a Ryan Gosling or when I
get to go to work with Paul even though
Paul Rudd has become a friend of mine
because I've worked with him so much
he's still like I'm like you Scott lay
you're a man man like I'll see him in
his costume so I don't have any strategy
because I can't I think if I think about
it too much
and I try to be if I tell myself in the
in the circumstances where I've said to
myself like don't be a dork don't be and
don't be a don't be a doofus don't
embarrass yourself then I ended up even
making it worse so I have to turn off
that it's so we're - actually if you
think about it like this like I have to
turn off this this one part of my
twelve-year-old brain yeah I don't I
don't tear up and I also then have to
keep this part of my twelve-year-old
brain completely alive because that's
when I'll do my best work right
as an actor I think the best I can do is
being like a 12 year old I'm just
playing make bleep it's crazy it helps
if I'm like super tired because then I'm
not too open but then I'm like I feel
like I'm like dialing back my excitement
just a little bit to the part I can just
be like I'm a big fan of yours
then I will always then I next time I
see you Harrison Ford I'm gonna make
sure I haven't slept in days I'll keep
my four-month old to keep me awake all
night yes I tired often because I have
two kids that run me ragged but yes
that's a good trick you're right how
does this work because I don't have any
significant free time so how do you have
like children and a wife and then work
all the time
amazing wife I'm taking this straight to
you I would not be able to do any of
this without you it's a truth I've got
the best partner for this and that's I I
sometimes wonder like how the heck would
I do this I was just last two months ago
we're shooting ant-man in the wasp in
Atlanta which is going awesome by the
way I can't wait for you guys to see
this oh my gosh it's going to be very
big film if it's going to we'll see a
big but for a small superhero okay
back so we were shooting you know like
my family flies to Chicago to start a
different film that we're working on an
ant-man had to keep me a couple extra
days in Atlantic because the schedule
changed and I was shooting until 1:00 in
the morning then you fly to Chicago and
shoot 7:00 in the morning until the that
night on a different thing and I I was
like like if I was a replicant I would
have to go into like hibernation for
medics my brain was starting to you know
like hotwire a little bit but you just
do it and and and any any time it's like
that 5:00 a.m. alarm goes off and I know
someone's picking me up in ten minutes
and I'm like oh watch transformers with
my kid when he wakes up you you go but
wait I'm going to I'm going to go didn't
Laboratories did it blown up like come
on give me a break
I'm so excited because I'm so excited to
see Evangeline really take an ass she's
such a badass she's such a bad I was a
huge lost fan and I've always loved her
and everything she's popped up in and I
think she's an insanely talented person
but um it's cool I'm excited that I get
to be a part of you know this is the
first Marvel film that has a female
character in its title mm-hmm she is you
know she's she's she's a hero of this
film and it's like what time I get to do
on set with her so far in filming has
been has been a blast and I I know that
there's been some pictures leaked of the
wasp costume but like
it's so badass man it's so cool yeah so
it skirt up this time
Curtis did the hair you mean yes it's I
and it was really cool that you know
Peyton came to me and he's like we want
to give Curt some superpowers for this
new film and so he's given me the
ability to like I can shoot things out
of my pompadour and you know I wish i
control-alt-delete the Anne tirage as we
lovingly call them
we're legitimately starting like a real
kind of business venture when the movie
begins with Scott Lang Paul and as
things happen to do and adventure films
things go awry the way that you expect
and an us three seem to always focus on
the the least consequential matters of
of the moment like what kind of snacks
are laying around or you know it's it's
really fun that's so surreal - you talk
about like what's weird and and being a
geek like my the connection in my life
to this world like so being a part of
ant-man
doesn't mean I'm just getting to be a
part of Scott Lang's adventure or you
know hopefully and Dynes adventure or
Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne now we know
that Michele's playing Janet it's like I
mean I grew up I one of my first long
committed monthly collections was the
West Coast Avengers and hank was a big
part of that and then I got really into
wasp and then I started to go back
further into the Avengers but I threw
this universe and threw things that you
know you're gonna see in the film the
connection that this has to the rest of
the Marvel Cinematic and Marvel you know
just the Marvel Universe whether it's a
cinematic or not like knowing that we're
part of that that like you know Captain
America could come walking in the door
at any minute or you know Doctor Doom
could all of a sudden show up and wreak
havoc on San Francisco it's like that's
help
awesome so you have Bolivar under 20 49
coming out yeah I just saw it last night
this weekend I know you can't say much
about the character Koko but what can
you say Koko not sick sorry I said I
sent a link to the Pixar trailer to
Denis and I said I'm so honored you
actually renamed your film from Blade
Runner 20 49 to a movie about me and I
and then I like dot that oh crap I'm
wrong movie so casually Koko yeah and
and I'm really blessed I'm fortunate
speaking of Danny really quickly so you
guys see this movie people out there in
the world of geek land and all people
who love movies I've never seen anything
like Blade Runner 2049 I've never seen
anything like this it is a game-changing
film that's my endorsement of the movie
i sat there last night in a theater
because you didn't know no I haven't
seen a lick of anyone used of us have
seen only only trailers and stuff so I
worked with Denis in 2013 on prisoners
time goes by and that was such an
incredible experience and I got to know
him really well and when I heard that he
was doing Blade Runner I just it was one
of those things that I couldn't stop
what thinking about her being like but
he's your friend and you do you how do
you get to be I do you can't like hey
you can't like assume - I heard you're
interviewing so-and-so can you bring me
a lot you know you can't do that I'd let
go of it because at that point they
denounced a ton of cast and like now a
year had gone by and I was like oh it's
there's no way I'm ever gonna get to
work on the film so I can't wait to see
it at that point that's where my mind
was like I cannot wait to see what Denis
Villeneuve does with the Blade Runner
world and I got this email one morning
and after you see the film and when we
can talk more about plot points I will
tell you exactly what it said it was a
moment that like I'll never forget
without giving too much away it's
thinking about like I want to bring you
far into the future that that that yeah
it was insane life-changing so I get to
play this character called Coco Coco who
works as a co-worker of Kay played by
Ryan Gosling I'm a nerd
surprise surprise I'm the guy nerds
typecasting but I work in the lab I get
to go through some pretty cool stuff and
interacting with the technology and the
vision that Denis and the rest of the
team like Gastner whoo-hoo Dennis
Gassner who production designed it and
and and the whole the whole company the
way they built and made that future look
in the film I can't wait for people to
see because it's not that glassy
idealized streamlined version of the
future that we've seen done really well
you know it's it's it's the opposite of
like Minority Report do mean yeah like
tech is actually starting to like fall
apart and this is the infrastructure of
the society is kind of in disarray and
so the things fueling the things and the
things that that construct the things
are just the world's not in a great
place in this vision of the future size
can be too real it's your break I know
so it's like it was it's really cool how
do we get you into the next Star Wars
movie then because I think that's the
only thing left JJ so we got a head JJ
hi mr. Abrams this is my audition tape
actually this whole thing is a ruse that
I created with ash I appreciate that
I will also be in the film yes we're
gonna play to it yeah the two Jedi who
who show up and basically save the
galaxy at the end of episode 9 we will
be raised parents you know I might be a
little young to play Ray's mom but I'll
do it
I I don't know how you make I don't know
how anything happens sometimes with it
comes to this kind of stuff but I you
know if if if I could be someone in a
cantina I'm sure you feel the same way
oh yeah I would be like a stormtrooper
extra that'd be great I would I mean I'm
not even an actor part be in a heartbeat
and and and or just carry a you know
carry a glass across the back of a shot
the movies have been so me I mean I've
only seen obviously as the rest of us
have only seen episode 7 but you're not
hanging out with ryan johnson just
watching dailies am i seeing his cuts
but no i
I'm I'm so excited for episode 8 I can't
really describe it and then and then to
see where it's going to go and I I feel
so like we're we're so lucky that we get
to be at this time you know having
experienced the magic of it as kids and
then now getting to like take it all in
and revisit it in such a fantastic way
as adults it's it's awesome and I get to
now I'm a dad you know how cool it's
that is so important I showed you
pictures I showed you picture of my
daughter the other day we have dressed
up like Princess Leia and it's like man
come on how awesome is that how is how
is not new father renew fatherhood
second bit second time around baby baby
there's no months ago yeah there's
there's there's a lot of stuff that you
are like oh I got this because I did it
the first time and now this is this is
we know how this works and then there's
the the exhaustion factor when you're
like oh yeah I forgot now I'm chasing a
three-year-old around and trying to keep
him from you know blowing up you know my
car and then and well you know and
managing a four month old thankfully our
four month old Penelope we call her
penny she's like a little Jedi she is a
little ball of Zen energy she's very
peaceful and she's very giggly and she's
just a little and she's very quiet and
my three and a half year old Arlo he is
like he'd be like a bounty hunter you
know he'd be like but but like like a
ruff-ruff Scalia and like guy that would
be hanging out you know he's a wild man
and and and he's kind of got likes flash
like speed ability which is really
tricky sometimes when you're trying to
chase him around the house so he keeps
us on our toes but I you know I have the
best like I'll keep saying it and and I
hope that she watches this and takes me
out for a date after but it's true I
have the best the best partner for this
stuff and and she still find time to
like finish the night get a comic out
read watch you know the latest episode
of whatever thing were
in the midst of you know devouring you
know or whatever movie we want yeah it's
pretty awesome goals goals hashtag
hashtag blessed well thank you so much
for coming in thanks for having me I
mean we we met on the carpet at it man
yeah man yeah do you believe now it's
almost that's three years ago this
coming around yeah that's time flies but
I'm I always love talking to you and I
love meeting fellow geeks and you're the
best you're the past oh you're the best
people I know go on
oh my gosh well you guys got a see blade
around her 2049 in theaters to morrow I
see it yeah and I want to plug really
quickly oh all creatures a movie that I
wrote stars Karen Gillan our very own
nebula yeah who is also you know Amy
Pond and who's in the new Jumanji film
so Bo piggybacking on all of her big
huge amazing accomplishments as an actor
I will say in our small tiny very
personal film that I wrote and act with
her and she delivers a performance that
I think is going to just melt people's
minds and hearts she's insanely talented
so I don't I wish I had news about when
that's when do we get to see it but just
to plant that little seed please keep
that up there and send us good vibes
because when it comes to independent
films you know it's very hard to like
find the way to get it out to people but
I'm very proud of that we're gonna we're
gonna do it so that's sorry my looked a
little plug there please yeah please
please plug away cool well thank you
guys so much I will see you guys next
time
see you next time see you next time